bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver tout de suite on passe au
sommaire cyclisme le prologue du
parenisétait programmé ce dimanche à
morpas et le champion du monde polonais
Michel kakovski qui s'est imposé sur le
contrôle à montre devant l'Australien
ran Denis nous recevrons notre
consultant cyclisme Yan du Jarrier pour
débriefer la compétition
par inice toujours ils étaient plus de
30000 dans les rues de morpa pour
encourager des coureurs sur le S
prologue nous y reviendrons dans cette
édition rugby le coach du Racing méro 92
Laurent Travers c'était dans les locaux
du comité départemental de rugby à
hencour l'entraîneur est venu animé un
atelier baptisé le management d'une
équipe de
rugby et puis en fin d'émission vous
retrouverez tous les résultats du
département ce
weekend je vous disais dans les titres
le prologue du parenis sétait organisé
ce dimanche à morpa sur le bitumivlinois
c'est le champion du monde polonais
Michal kakowski qui s'est imposé sur le
contrôle à montre devant l'Australien
ran de Nice le montage est signé romain
rusmin les cyclistes ont fait le show
sur le bitum de morpa pour ce prologue
du Parisis c'est finalement le jeune
champion du monde polonais Michel
katowski de l'équipe belge ethique
quickstep qui s'est imposé ce dimanche
en 7 minutes et 40 secondes sur ce
contre la montre il a dévancé pour 31
petit stiè le détenteur du record de
l'UR l'Australien ran Denis l'Allemand
Tony Martin complète le podium on tombe
sur un coureur qui est très àroit parce
que je crois que si mes souvenirs sont
bon il doit venir un petit peu du
cyclross ou du VTT et sur un parcours
comme ça ça aide énormément il est jeune
donc il a vraiment la volonté de d'aller
chercher une belle victoire et je pense
que il faudra aller le chercher les
Français ont déçu sur ce prologue du
parinis Sylvain chavenel réalise le
meilleur temps en 7 minutes 50 secondes
le deuxè français Tony galopin termine
lui à la 20 place du classement le
prologue rien du tout c'est quelque
chose de très particulier donc on peut
pas tirer des conclusions sur ce genre
d'effort je pense que les première
conclusion seront attirer justement à la
croix de chauouré maintenant il leur
reste à attaquer il leur reste à les
mettre en difficulté tous ceux qui sont
les les les grands leaders de de parinis
il y a pas de raison on peut attaquer de
loin malgré des performances timoré sur
ce prologue tout espoir n'est pas perdu
pour les cyclistes tricolor le français
Jean-Christophe perra 27e à morpa fait
tout toujours parti des prétendants la
victoire finale la course du soleil
donnera son verdict ce dimanche du côté
de
Nice pour débf et ce parénis nous
recevons sur ce plateau Yann Dujarier
qui a été champion d'Europe sur piste en
2013 alors vraiment vous en avez pris
plein les yeux he sur ce prologue du
parisissant c'est c'est des épreuves
enin l'épreuve du prologue ou du
contrôle à mon de toute façon c'est des
endroits où justement on prend beaucoup
de beaucoup de plaisir le matériel est
quand même bien particulier c'est
toujours très beau hier on avait une
très belle météo et euh et donc oui
c'est clair que les voir grimper aux all
auquel ils peuvent passer et relancer et
les vitesses qui sont atteintes sont
vraiment c'est vraiment impressionnant
et est-ce que ce polonais donc Michel
kakovski a réussi donc enfin a été un
beau vainqueur de de
ce c'est juste le Champion du monde en
titre sur route c'est pas un inconnu
c'est un très jeune maintenant c'est
vrai que c'est la première fois qu'il se
révèle sur un sur un type d'effort type
prologue j'ai c'est une petite surprise
peut-être surprise non parce que enfin
quand un gar gagne des courses
régulièrement on peut on peut l'attendre
mais c'est vrai que là c'est quand même
un effort très particulier c'est une des
premières fois où il se révèle sur ce
type
d'effort un coureur à suivre parce que
Ben un peu passe partout sur sur pas mal
de de points un petit peu dans la
nouvelle génération des coureurs
comme je pe trouver son nom mais bon
c'est pas grave des des nouveaux
coureurs qui qui sont un peu un petit
peu passent partout et qui qui brille
qui bruit déjà très très jeune et
qu'est-ce qui a fait la différence
justement sur ce contrôle à montre euh
la différence ah ben ce qui fait la
différence peut-être pour lui c'est
d'être parti ouais pour lui c'est d'être
parti tard il est parti après Tony
Martin il avait des qui de son équipe et
il avait des informations de temps sur
sur le prologue donc du coup il savait
où est-ce qu'il était placé et bon après
ça s'est joué de toute façon dans les
deux derniers kilomètres sur le plat où
il fallait il a fallu envoyer mais c'est
vrai qu'il avait des informations sur le
sur le grâce à Tony Martin il a été bien
préparé justement euh je pense que bah
toute façon l'équipe quickstep enfin
l'équipe ex quickstep est une très
grosse formation ils savent préparer
très très bien leur leur leurs objectifs
ils sont ils sont là pour pour faire des
résultats voilà c'est c'est les grosses
c'est les grosses écuries du du du
Pluton World Tour qui font la différence
on attendait le le Britannique Bradley
Wiggins on attendait peut-être aussi
rich porte finalement ils ont plutôt
déçu sur cette compétion enfin sur ce
premier jour en tout cas c'est vrai que
sur le papier ben ce sont des des
coureurs qui peuvent prétend la victoire
sur sur parinis quand on regarde encore
l'Étap enfin quand on regarde l'Étap
d'aujourd'hui moi j'ai l'impression par
wigin c'est là vraiment pour se préparer
il est là pour rouler il a fait
énormément d'efforts en tête de pleloton
aujourd'hui juste pour imprimer un train
mais en puissance selon vous peut-être
pas sur cette semaine je sais que ses
objectifs sont sont sur le mois d'avril
voilà il est là pour pour travailler et
c'est pas Bradley Wiggins qui qui qu'il
faut attendre sur sur la semaine et donc
un petit mot également sur sur le
parcours il était vraiment très bien
dessiné ce parcours très beau parcours
on le connaissait pour y avoir couru les
les années précédentes au niveau
régional euh c'est ouais c'est c'est
très très sympa de de voir les coureurs
pro sur sur les mêmes sur les mêmes
étapes ou sur les mêmes épreuves que que
nous on peut réaliser c'est toujours
c'est toujours agréable et donc il y
avait la fameuse rue de la Tour vous y
étz étiez vous à cet endroit euh vous
les avez senti comment justement les
coureurs ils étaient soufflés vraiment
essouffl ils avaient du mal dans cette
dans cette côte c'est c'est pour eux
c'est pas des c'est pas des c'est pas
d'é Coles ils ont ils ont l'habitude de
faire de de la haute montagne donc voilà
ça ça passe bien
c'est quand même des efforts qui
demandent qui demandent ouais qui
demandent des qualités des qualités
supérieures pour pour le faire ha
vitesse auquel ils le font le prologue
se gagne quand même à plus de 52 kmh 7
km 6 km 700 en 7 minutes 40 c'est c'est
juste c'est juste bluffant en tout cas
vous avez apprécié ce prologue à morp
j'ai pris beaucoup de plaisir une autre
personnalité du monde du cyclisme
apprécié donc ce prologue à morpass et
François Le mararchand le directeur du
parisce nous l'avons rencontré juste
après la course
nous sommes avec François le mararchand
directeur du Paris Nice alors c'était
une belle course aujourd'hui vraiment
très belle course sous un soleil radieux
c'est on appelle cette épreuve la Course
au Soleil et aujourd'hui on a été on a
été gâté un très beau prologue un
prologue en pleine campagne avec une
difficulté avec du public avec un beau
vainqueur un champion du monde sur route
qui va porter demain le le leader de
parinis donc pour nous c'est une belle
journée de vélo et Michel katovski
justement le le vainqueur du jour c'est
vraiment l'espoir sur ces prochaines
années et en tout cas sur ce Paris Nice
bah l'espoir oui parce que les deux
dernières années sur le Tour de France
il il a porté à plusieurs reprise le
maillot blanc de meilleurs jeunes donc
c'est quand même un coureur qui est
assez régulier dans le classement
général et aussi il a de bonne qualité
pour passer la montagne sur par il y a
pas de haute montagne c'est la moyenne
montagne et moi j'en fais mon favori
pour pour cette édition les Français
n'ont pas été trop au rendez-vous he sur
cette épreuve
ils n'ont pas été au rendez-vous mais je
pense qu'on dans les prochains jours
notamment à l'arrivée à la croix de
chouré il y a des choses à faire il faut
leur laisser le temps on a on a des
coururs qui ont qui ont du talent qui
ont des objectifs peut-être un peu plus
lointains mais on a Tony galopin qui qui
qui est malgré tout très en forme
Sylvain Chavanel qui qui est très en
forme et justement j'espère que ces
garçons vont profiter des étapes de
pleaine demain après-demain et jusqu'à
la Crot choubouré pour essayer de
renverser la situation essayer de de
redonner du jeu à ce à ce parinis et
donc pour vous les Français ont
clairement une chance dans ce parénis
ils sont pas horors course en tout cas
ah non pas du tout du tout pas du tout
pas du tout il y a un Romain Bardet qui
qui a fait deétape de la CRO chououret
son objectif de de la semaine non non
après il faut trouver des solutions
katovski fait partie d'une équipe
ethique Quick Step qui est très forte
collectivement donc ben il le but c'est
de déstabiliser cette équipe et on
compte sur les français pour cela on
leur a amené du soleil on leur a proposé
un beau parcours et je pense que
qu'aujourd'hui ils peuvent s'exprimer et
on attend beaucoup d'eux le public a
vraiment répondu présent il y avait
entre 20000 et 30000 personnes
aujourd'hui bien oui l'an passé à à
Monte la jolie il faisait un temps
identique il y en avait également
beaucoup de monde c'était une épreuve en
ligne et avec la victoire de Nasser
Bouani aujourd'hui c'est un prologue
donc étalé sur 3h et bien ça fait du
spectacle ça permet au aux spectateurs
de découvrir les les coureurs un par un
et avec cette journée là c'est la la la
plus belle journée depuis depuis 3 mois
donc les gens sortent c'est un dimanche
donc c'est c'est bon pour pour tout le
monde c'est bon pour pariniis c'est bon
pour le cyclisme et c'est bon pour pour
ce sport qui qui est accessible et
gratuit pour pour le public merci
François Le Marchand merci François Le
Marchand le directeur du parinis l'a dit
pendant l'interview les Français ont été
vraiment en difficulté hein sur ce
Prolog ouais comme depuis plusieurs
années c'est vrai qu'on a pas de de gros
rouleurs qui peuv se permettre de de
rivaliser avec les avec les meilleurs
mondiaux sur sur tout ce qui est contre
la montre Sylvain Chavanel est à sa
place une belle 7e ou 8e place je crois
il est voilà il est il est placé comme
comme depuis depuis toujours Tony
galopin moi je pense qu' qu'il est
peut-être justement un coureur à à en
devenir sur sur ce type ce type d'effort
mais voilà faut pas non plus on n pas on
n pas ces coureurs là bon c'est pas
grave on a des coureurs qui peuvent
briller dans dans beaucoup d'autres
disciplines dans dans le vélo on a très
bon grimpeur on a de très bon très bon
sprinterur c'est pas c'est pas gênant on
sait quand on est sur le départ d'un
d'un contrre à montre syvin Chan Vanel
justement qui qui était 7e donc à
l'arrivée c'est une surprise ou il était
vraiment attendu selon vous il est il
est à sa place c'est c'est ce qui fait
tout le temps sur sur le Tour de France
il est un poil en dessous parce que
benah la densité fait que il se retrouve
un peu derrière mais sur un championnat
du monde c'est c'est souvent voilà
autour de la 10 15e place là voilà se
retrouver en 8e position sur sur un
Parini sur un prologue de Parini c'est
pas c'est pas choquant c'est c'est
normal il a fait une bonne course il
fait il fait ce qu'il fait avec ses
moyens et il fait il fait comme il peut
il est placé pour le général c'est vrai
que c'est un coureur un coureur qui a
qui a plusieurs cartes à son à son à son
dans S dans ouais qui a plusieurs cartes
dans ses
l'avant dernière étape pourra lui être
lui être favorable c'est une étape c'est
vraiment une étape pour pour puncher
donc voilà le fait d'être placé d'être
en ambuscade ça peut permettre de de
faire des choses sur sur la dernière
semaine sur la l'avantdernière étape
donc le prologue était pas vraiment fait
pour pour nos Français justement bah non
de toute façon voilà même le contre la
montre du Coles dimanche contre la
montre en côte ce sera pas non plus pour
pour nos Français ou à moins d'avoir une
une vraie révélation et une vraie
surprise mais moi je je le vois pas
voilà voilà les pour moi les les espoirs
français s'arrêteront samedi mais on a
beaucoup de chance d'ici jusque là pour
pour remporter des étapes donc vous nous
rassurez he les les espoirs français
sont pas terminés hein non on peut voir
on peut être optimiste bien sûr et voir
des des Français sur le podium comme
l'année dernière à l'arrivée à Paris à
l'arrivée à Nice c'est c'est
envisageable largement le Paris Nice
donc a été un succès sur le bitu mais
également sur les bords de route les
passionnés de cyclisme sont venus en
nombre ce dimanche pour encourager les
coururs du parinis au total ils étaient
plus de 30000 les IM signé à Flor
parf la cour cycliste parénis passionne
toujours autant les foules ce dimanche
plus de 3000 spectateurs ont assisté au
prologue qui se disputait dans les rues
de morpa dans le public sous un soleil
printagen on pouvait apercevoir des
jeunes amateurs de cyclisme ça me plaît
parce que de voir des courir en vélo
parce que j'aime beaucoup le vélo alors
les voir courir aussi vite ça ça fait
vraiment plaisir les motifs des des cas
me plaît vraiment quelques printemps de
plus pour ces passionnés de cyclisme
mais l'enthousiasme est bien présent
parce que je suis un passionné de
cycliste hein parce que je m'intéresse
toujours au cours cycliste professionnel
professionnel et et autre et puis que je
pratique le vélo à titre cyclotouriste
je soutiens tout le monde tout le monde
et les Français en particulier jeune ou
moins jeune tous sont unanimes le
chouchou du public c'est lui Thomas
vauler le coureur d'Europe car a pu
mesurer une nouvelle fois sa côte de
popularité sur ce prologue son statut de
star du cyclisme français est toujours
intact malgré ses 35 ans on aime bien
les équipes françaises donc plutôt
plutôt les Français oui d'accord et vous
avez peut-être un courir français que
vous vous aimez bien on aime bien Thomas
vcller vaucller parce qu'on l'a vu quand
quand on l'a roulé ce matin puis voilà
c'est ton vraiment ton courur favori
ouais j'aime bien loin de ces glorieuses
années Thomas vauler aura 36 ans en juin
et pourrait se retirer du monde du
cyclisme l'année prochaine les
spectateurs seront une nouvelle fois au
rendez-vous du parénis en 2016 dans les
ivelines le départ de la Course au
Soleil sera donné depuis le département
pendant encore 2 ans au minimum les
ivinois ne vont pas s'en plaindre
allez Yan on l'a vu dans le reportage il
y avait vraiment beaucoup de monde hein
sur sur les routes bah oui c'est vrai
que alors la
météo ou non puis la météo la météo le
permettait c'est vrai que c'était cétait
très sympa une zone aussi facile d'accès
c'est vrai que pour se garer au départ
c'était idéal on était aussi très proche
de la très proche de la côte l'élément
le plus le plus imp plus sympa à à voir
à venir voir sur sur la course donc
c'est vrai que c'était c'était vraiment
bien bien organisé par euh par les gens
qui ont tracé qu' on tracé le parcours
bien pensé voilà
euh et puis le vélo voilà c'est c'est
c'est un sport gratuit on n' pas besoin
de payer pour venir voir les coureurs
les coureurs sont aussi abordables vous
pouvez venir discuter avec eux une fois
qu'ils ont fini leur leurs prologue ils
sont euh ils sont vraiment ouvert j'ai
vu des gens rouler entre le l'arrivée et
le départ rouler à côté d'eux et
discuter avec avec certains
des photos sur les réseaux sociaux et
même hier j'en ai croisé quelques-uns
donc c'est vrai que bah c'est c'est ça
c'est la farveur populaire du du
cyclisme et c'est quel type de public
justement c'était plutôt des familles
c'est voilà ouais c'est c'est accessible
à tout le monde vous avez pas besoin de
connaître les coureurs pour venir les
voir vous avez pas besoin de connaître
le vélo pour apprécier le spectacle
apprécier le matériel apprécier
apprécier cette ambiance et puis et puis
voilà voir voir des des beau coureurs
rouler vite c'est c'est quand même
toujours c'est toujours intéressant et
ils étaient positionnés où sur sur la
course principalement j'ai j'ai vraiment
eu l'impression qu'ils étaient partout
hein peut-être pas dans la descente et
c'est le seul endroit où je suis pas
allé mais c'est vrai que Y en tout cas
dans dans la côte justement la rue de la
Tour dans la côte il y av Ava y avait du
monde il y avait du monde à l'arrivée il
y avait du monde au départ c'était
c'était une belle fête une belle fête
populaire comme le mérite le cyclisme et
c'était un public plutôt Chauvin ou
justement ils encourageaient un petit
peu les coureurs étrangers également
alors comme d'habitude et maintenant
enfin moi c'est c'est vrai quelque chose
qui que j'apprécie parce que je le suis
je le suis aussi c'est vraiment un
public très chauud dans la côte quand on
voyait passer les Français les
encouragement n'était pas les mêmes que
pour que pour les coureurs étrangers et
tant mieux il faut garder cette cette
ferveur et et puis voilà on est on est
bleu blanc rouge avant tout et il faut
il faut rester comme ça il y a pas de
souci et vous avez vu des étrangers
également sur sur les bords de route non
là j'ai pas
ouais alors après est-ce que c'était des
accompagnateurs est-ce que c'était du
personnel encadrant j'ai j'ai pas fait
attention non je je peux pas je peux pas
dire en tout cas cétait un rendez-vous
parfait pour pour les familles en tout
cas c'était le bon dimanche après-midi à
passer au soleil en promenade et euh euh
en campagne donc voilà oua c'était
c'était l'événement paraté ce weekend
sur sur 50 anseling le Paris donc c'est
un événement qui prépare le Tour de
France le directeur du Tour de France
justement Christian prudom était
justement au départ de l'étape il
revient sur cette journée sur lesépreuve
du
parinis nous sommes avec Christian
prudom directeur d'amouris Sport
Organisation alors c'est une belle
journé belle journée aujourd'hui oui ça
il fait très beau la course au sola il
mérite son nom on a souvent de la chance
quand on part des evelines parce qu'on a
toujours du beau temps et en plus il
fait beau et pres Chud donc c'est
parfait et pourquoi pourquoi Mor pas
justement écoutez nous avons une
convention avec le département avec le
Conseil Général des yelines c'est la la
6è fois que que nous sommes dans le
cadre de ce partenariat et le choix
s'est porté cette année sur morpa pour
le contre la montre initiale et sur
saintém Chevreuse pour le départ de la
première étable demain il y a vraiment
un beau plateau installé il y a un
plateau extrêmement dense à la fois de
rouleur de grand sprinter l'homme le
plus en forme du début de saison
Alexander Christophe griple que le
speaker vient d'annoncer à l'instant
l'allemand et de et puis les Français
demmar
BR comm Fran
commonéta pasour ESP Brill sur spinis et
puis de jeunes étrangers comme harou
italien oual polonais meilleur griur du
dernier Tour de France et les premières
étapes peuvent être décisive ah décisive
je sais pas vous savez sur Paris Nice
c'est une course qui se joue toujours à
coup de seconde la moindre seconde gagné
ou perdu est importante donc d Mor pas
cont la monre mor pas mais aussi jusqu'à
Nice avec le contre la montre finale et
puis a une arrivée au sommet la croix de
chauouret a-udessus de Saint-Étienne
mais c'est vrai que ça peut jouer
partout par ça peut jouer dans le vent
qui forme ce qu'on appelle des bordures
le Pluton qui scin dans plusieurs partie
sous l'effet du vent ça peut se jouer le
samedi dans l'arrière payinissois
parinis c'est vraiment une question de
seconde donc j'espère que de ce point de
vue là en tout cas et avec le soleil
aussi la la logique sera conforme à la
tradition et en tout cas il y a du monde
aujourd'hui c'est c'est vraiment un beau
rendez-vous pour tout le cyclisme dans
les iblines oui parce que c'est un
département où il y a beaucoup de cyclos
des gens qui roulent avec la proximité
de la Chevreuse on l'a vu d'ailleurs
avec les randonnées organisées à morpa
avec plus de 800 participants donc c'est
c'est quelque chose de de bien de fort
et et et plus les gens seront au
quotidien sur leur bicyclette ou leur
vélo ben plus ils regarderont avec avec
des yeux de passion les champions du
cyclisme merci Christian
fredom le parénis continue il y avait la
première la première étape du coup de ce
parénis aujourd'hui au départ de saint-m
les chevreus vous avez regardé Yan
justement cette étape bien sûr comme à
chaque fois qu'il y a une étape enfin
une course de de vélo retransmise à la
télé j'essaie de j'essaie de me tenir
informer ou de regarder euh oui donc
despurs de s Chevreuse on a vu Thomas
weuckler partir en échapper et faire 150
km d'échappé repris à 2 km de l'arrivée
et un très beau spray enfin non pas un
beau sprint un sprint très brouillon
remporté par Alexander Christoff voilà
c'est un norvégien ouais qui domine qui
domine le sprint en début de saison là
il a il a gagné si six courses
différentes depuis depuis le début de la
de l'année euh nos deux français termine
au 2è et 3e place avec Nasser BO
justement ils se reprennent bien
justement nos Français oui oui bien sûr
ouais oua c'était pas ça mais par contre
sur l'Étap d'aujourd'hui c'est c'était
ça on on a encore deux étapes de sprint
demain et après-demain euh bah ouais il
va peut-être falloir changer des mettre
des stratégies mettre Nasser buani
termine 2uxème et puis Brian Cocar 3e
notre notre petit PISTAR de poche là qui
qui fait un très beau finish sur sur le
sprint euh voilà ils sont toujours prêts
aux accessites pour moi ouais nasserb a
largement de quoi faire pour pour gagner
une étape sur ce parénis il a perdu son
poisson pilote malade dès dès ce matin
là Geoffrey soupe n'est pas n'est pas
reparti ce matin sur Paris Nice euh
c'est pas et voilà il va falloir que
l'équipe
se module différemment pour pouvoir
l'emmener correctement et idem pour la
FDJ il va falloir travailler pour un
démar qui aujourd'hui était très très
mal placé pour pour l'arrivée merci yen
du jarier d'être passé sur ce plateau
c'est un plaisir comme d'habitude nous
passons tout de suite aux autres
résultats du
[Musique]
weekend
lundi dernier le coach du Racing MRO 92
Laurent traverse était dans les locaux
du comité départemental de rugby à
aencour l'entraîneur vainqueur du Top 14
avec le castre olympique en 2013 est
venu animer un atelier baptisé le
management d'une équipe de rugby une
soirée de formation destinée aux
éducateur et coach ivinois cette
opération s'est effectuée dans le cadre
d'un partenariat entre le Conseil
Général des ivines et le club du Racing
Métro on écoute Leurent travers je vais
pouvoir exposer suite à l'expérience que
ça soit professionnelle ou sportif
voilà ce qu'on a pu ce qu'on a pu
s'apercevoir est ce qui est ce qui est
bien ou pas bien ce qui nous paraît être
bien ou pas bien après on est pas là
pour faire la science infuse et donner
des cours on est là surtout pour
indiquer ce qui nous paraît comme je
vous l'ai dit auparavant ce qui nous
paraît bien pour un joueur de façon à ce
qu' soit le plus performant possible et
que ça soit pareil dans le monde de
l'entreprise comme dans le monde sportif
on commence les résultats du weekend par
du rugby et le championnat de Promotion
d'Honneur 51vine a remporté une courte
mais une précieuse victoire sur le
terrain d'lné lors de la 16e journée les
antinois se sont imposés 20 à 17 chez
leur adversairire du jour 501 en yine
reste secondde de ce championnat avec 50
points enrangé la première place sera
difficile à aller chercher les
cinquantinois contte 5 points de retard
sur Massif Central toujours en rugby
mais cette fois-ci en première série
montinil au bretonux s'est facilement
imposé sur le terrain du blancménil ce
dimanche score finale 27 à 5 la défense
inemontaine a été au rendez-vous de
l'événement avec CIN petits points
encaissés mon breteneux conserve la 2uxe
place du classement avec 65 points en 16
journées l'équipe de Cyril murier
réalise une superbe saison avec
seulement trois défaites depuis
septembre en handball féminin montinilo
breton est dans la difficulté leader au
mois de janvier les filles de Philippe
l'étrange ont enregistré une nouvelle
défaite à l'extérieur les inimontaines
se sont inclinés 32 à 26 du côté du
classement montinilo Bretonneux
dégringole à la 4e place les ivlinois se
retrouvent désormais à 4 points du
leader valdorge à 6 journées de la fin
du championnat simontin retrouve son jeu
les joueuses de Philippe l'étrange
peuvent toujours espérer terminer aux
deux premières places du classement on
passe au football nouvelle
contreperformance à domicile pour trappe
les les traapistes ont été tenus en
échec sur leur terrain contre
sainttoilomon score final trois buts
partout l'attaque a été en réussite avec
trois petit but inscrit mais c'est la
défense qui a failli sur cette rencontre
du classement au niveau du classement ça
ne bouge pas ou presque trappe reste à
la 8e place du championnat à égalité de
point avec puto et le PEC avec la
nouvelle défaite de chantlou levvine
contre puto trappe devrait se maintenir
cette année c'est la fin de ce 78 sport
j'étais très heureux de vous avoir
pendant cette demi-heur d'information je
vous retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau magazine en attendant passer
une excellente semaine
sportive